no
that's not him that's not him Maria
come on figure it out oh she figured it
out oh my god oh no Kobe and Soren's
already dead we don't have any other
outs yeah
don't shoot her again
watching you kill someone I mean yeah oh
my God it's Sam Jackson and Hugh Jackman
have experienced this yeah that's my
favorite one
smiles
this guy I like him he's so good I hate
him
oh no
oh
that's how she dies thinking that it was
him I told you she had to figure it out
do you think she figured it out I think
she did I think she was I think she said
it was you was kind of like a warning
okay like to like go find you in the
crowd I mean you're dying those are your
last thoughts I mean the previous last
words were like you've lost your touch
so yeah that's not a good way to go
what what kind of final image is this
oh my God rip Maria Hill all right P
Maria
forever
Kobe was like thank you I don't have to
do Marvel movies anymore
I will only sign on if there's a bullet
in my gut by the end oh my God guys I
can't believe they ended the first
episode this way this is this is a good
punch welcome back to new rock stars
secret Invasion Episode One kicked off
with a bang bit a bang then a bang then
bang bang bang a lot of Big Bangs uh we
say those vedania do a long time MCU
character Maria Hill if episode one can
kill off someone who's been with us
since 2012 in the MCU who else will die
on this show it's back on and I need you
guys to help me with this we're all
gonna whisper it together okay
scroll search
this is inside Marvel it's new
Rockstar's Marvel reaction show we have
changed things up here on inside Marvel
so that we are now in person we got our
West Coast Avengers here with us I'm
Eric Boss here with me it's Hector
Navarro and mod Garrett
hello hey hey what is this let me have
it okay I'm in America
uh I'm so excited to have both of you
here with us on the rockstars and for
those of you who might have joined me
rockstars in the past years so uh mod
well used to join us for our Westeros
weekly or Game of Thrones after shows
back a couple years ago and broke Theory
uh we used to do a show called new rock
stars news and the debrief model is a
big part of that so it's so wonderful
having you back
um welcome to be back the best and then
Hector you might know Hector from uh our
Wookie leaks this past season and a lot
of other new rock stars formats and you
guys have done stuff together
over the years and mod you're gonna be
happy to know this I watched the entire
first season of uh Game of Thrones House
of the Dragon you didn't it yeah hey
what'd you think secret invasion's great
and I can't wait to talk about it
there's not as much incest and um yeah
it's only episode one great we don't
know
yeah a lot of Scrolls a lot of scroll
stuff gonna be happening yes right I'm
so pumped to be uh chatting with both of
you for a number of reasons that you'll
see throughout this uh this after show
we're gonna be bringing our kind of
personal takes to what we see every
Wednesday whenever you watch this and a
reminder that inside Marvel is actually
now gonna be shifting over to the break
room channel on the new rockstars
Network for secret Invasion episode one
we are also releasing this after show on
the main channel so you could be
watching it there right now but if you
are watching this on on the main Channel
be sure to go over to the break room
because we're going to have an extended
version of this after show a couple
questions that are not in the main
Channel version of it oh bonus a bonus
scroll Search exclusive
um it's starting next week this will be
only on the break room so be sure to
subscribe to the break room
um you can also check out Tommy and Jay
Washington's reaction episode one that's
already on the channel or now they
stayed up late they were the late night
folks uh in my breakdown the Easter egg
breakdown is going to be on the main
Channel later today and be sure to check
out nerdright.shop where you can always
grab the latest and greatest in Newark
Search gear right now you can check out
our line of merch inspired by secret
Invasion support the channel and check
out our great merch options over a
nerdroid.shop and yet again please
subscribe to all three of our channels
the Deep dive the break room and new
rock stars this Logan needs to be wear
it if you want to fit in I like that if
you want to fit in and it's good I like
that okay let's talk about what happened
episode one okay we're just gonna recap
it we're gonna relive it we're gonna
re-traumatize ourselves
um we start with agent Everett Ross are
coming back he meets up with agent
Prescott uh who is played by the same
actor who does Barrick dondarian A Game
of Thrones he's a lightning Lord
um yeah
um he's gone full Pepe Silvia with this
Theory the scrolls are behind a series
of attacks around the globe uh he seems
paranoid and he's trying to prevent Ross
from leaving but Ross escapes they have
a fight and then uh this Prescott gets
shot through I it took me a second to
realize where the gunshot came right
yeah there's a blood leak right so he he
had the gun in his ankle holster right
right and then he just yeah
um I think they're just careful showing
where gunshots happen so early in an
episode on Disney plus maybe uh maybe I
don't know maybe
um he calls Maria Hill for an extraction
he's pursued in the streets by some
mysterious figure Ross jumps off a roof
feels very Men In Black opening to me
there's like a couple Men In Black
referencing
yes especially with uh the little girl
little girl
quantum physics yeah
[Laughter]
um so uh Maria Hill pulls around just to
see him badly wounded and the figure
stands over him and while Maria has her
gun aimed on him he shape shifts and
it's Talos uh Everett Ross passes away
but he also shapeshifts he was a scroll
and Taylor says he's one of them so now
it's this is them yeah who's the ass and
who's right and Taylor's is also a
scroll but the show is already
establishing like look there we're going
to give you new Scrolls that you were
not familiar with because up to this
point what have Scrolls been in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the movie
Captain Marvel and I think that's it and
then just Talos and his wife at the end
of Spider-Man far from home yeah there
was the one in one division who showed
up recruiting Monica Rambo being like
we're working up in space you're like
okay I guess she's gonna go up to the
saber station and then we'll see that in
the Marvel's movie later this year but
that's been it and and when Captain
Marvel the movie came out in 2019 and it
was set in 1995 I remember the internet
and comic book fans talking about
oh typically scrolls are just bad guys
right in Marvel Comics and this movie
makes you think they're bad guys and
they're kind of bad guys for a good
portion of it and then there's a Twist
where it's like oh no they're refugees
and and fury and Carol Danvers and Maria
Rambo they're all gonna help these
Scrolls the real villains are Jude Law
and the cree and so comic book fans are
going this is like an inversion of the
typical thing and this show I think is
trying to establish okay yes there are
good guy Scrolls we've humanized some of
those characters Talos and his wife and
so on but we're still going to have a
villainous side to these characters and
it's also another extension on the
aftermath of the blip yeah
it was catastrophic and it was for years
so what actually happened in this time
when we're looking at the aftermath of
it all and I think not only are we
seeing sort of like the demise of some
characters who went through some stuff
yeah but we're also seeing that um you
know life didn't stop for a lot of other
people especially those the Scrolls that
are refugees in survival mode it's true
we went over that in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier that show was also about
human beings that were like displaced
from the blip and I love anytime
anything in the MCU deals with what
happened in those five years well I'm
like I want more of that Spider-Man
where it was like well he's a school
report I know I know a single player got
tackled at a basketball game which I
think that I love what I call blit
fiction just focusing on these little
moments where characters are absent and
they come back and they chaos that
ensues like when Yelena came back in the
show Hawkeye flashbacks in a bathroom
she comes back and she's like where's my
sister I have to find my sister you're
like no girls we did I've been in
bathrooms where the wallpaper shifted
but it's because I was on different
drugs yeah I just had eight seven
but I think this show does a better job
with that kind of uh that blip aftermath
and they had a difficult task as you
mentioned Captain Marvel painted the
Scrolls all as good guys so just with
this one line he's one of them a
squirrel saying that already signals to
us that there's a different category of
Scrolls who are nefarious who are
enemies and we gotta look out for them
and it could be anyone it could be
anyone
so Nick Fury definitely feeling his age
reunites uh on Earth with Maria Hill and
with Talos and Taylor tries uh to ask
Fury how he's doing Fury's all business
yeah uh we learn about uh gravic who's I
love the name great graphic I'm gonna
call him gravic because I'm a dickensian
appreciator and I love it when they have
word play and character's names
I mean AKA The Commonwealth
they all sound like this or they're
Australian yeah that's true actually
okay Ben Mendelson who chucked a mate in
there yeah he's so happy about that
listen mate yeah
I love it I'm sorry um no uh so gravic
is the newest member of What's called
the scroll Council and he's using this
group called Americans against Russia
the AAR which I feel like aren't all
Americans against Russia right now
which
pushed it back a little bit like when
they were in the throes of War
possibly oh I I'm trying to remember too
if anybody here knows I know that most
Marvel projects always get announced and
then they're usually delayed for various
reasons obviously the global pandemic
was one reason a bunch of stuff got
delayed but then other people have been
pointing out like well with the incoming
writer strike and then maybe actor
strike and director strike or whatever
that Marvel and other companies have
been kind of banking a bunch of their
stuff and slowly spacing it because
remember originally this year was going
to be like a bunch of TV shows yeah and
then it's whittled down to like well
we're getting secret Invasion Loki
season two and then Echo echo's gonna
drop all at once at the end all at once
at the end of the year and people are
like well where's what if season two and
where like there's a couple of things
that have sort of like maybe they're
holding on so I don't know if but then
it could have also been real world
events that have caused Marvel Studios
to be like let's sit on secret Invasion
for a second and for a second yeah also
like I'd love to be a fly on the wall at
that board meeting where they're like
wow they're really making themselves a
better villain for
you
I mean Russians since the Cold War have
always been an easy villain because yeah
yes but but to your point mod I think
it's always been fascinating to know
that like you know that there was maybe
a meeting at Marvel in the year 2020
where they were like man we made a movie
where everyone just had to like
collectively mourn around the world for
years and now this Global event is
happening like if things weirdly line up
to what marvelous
it's so good that there's a conspiracy
now don't go too far down but it's a
little entertaining the show to do it in
it's the show to do it that
um The Whistleblower for the like the
upis the new word Fair UFOs
unidentified aerial phenomenons and the
Marvel is essentially integrating the no
and Aliens being on the planet to
actually help humans
wow conspiracy I love that that's not
what we trust remember when conspiracy
theories could just be harmless and fun
yeah and the aliens are that kind of
does yeah so you're saying the US
government's calling up Disney Marvel
Studios and going like can you put more
aliens and stuff so people don't freak
out when we actually have to let them
know
and they're looking at their comic books
and they're like yeah sure that stuff's
already been in there since the 60s but
okay yeah we'll put more why I mean
Marvel Comics began as propaganda with
Captain America
World War II oh man it's it's in its DNA
to spread this Chariot of the guy anyway
anyway
s that's now Canon
um so the a uh the AAR is actually a
scroll lead front as are all these
International terrorist cell groups that
Prescott was talking about their goal is
to start a war between Russia and the
United States it feels very Tom Clancy
right the sum of all fears uh this would
likely spell the end of human
civilization obviously the US and the
and Russia have the biggest stockpile of
nukes right
um in disbelief Yuri decides to go for a
walk alone and we uh get an appearance
from Colonel James Rhodes AKA Roadie who
was told by president ritzen German
Mulroney or Dylan McDermott who knows
which one it is
um yeah I love that they cast the guy
who like there was an SNL bit and no one
could tell them apart
um and uh so president ritzen tells uh
Rody to deal with Fury and Hill's AWOL
status Fury's Lonesome nightwalk ends
with being kidnapped and I think he you
know I think he expected to be kidnapped
honestly uh and coming to uh this fancy
room with Olivia Coleman's character
Sonia Farnsworth fallsworth excuse me I
have to make a very very clear that
Marvel is so lucky to get Olivia oh
absolutely but it's such a win for them
absolutely and I think also correct me
if I'm wrong too I wasn't she also very
excited to do it because she likes
Marvel movies and stuff or maybe she
mentioned that right I think that she
was just like down to clown because she
she's very much into this stuff which is
great she's fitting in perfectly and
playing this MI6 character I every
everything she's I mean this cast might
be the most stacked cast any of Disney
plus Marvel show has had it's good I I
don't think there's a weak link
um so Sonia wants to talk grab it uh
Fury wants to talk bomb supplies neither
really budge Fury eventually leaves but
not after Sonny tells him he's not ready
for the fight and fury bugs her room I
love putting this little contact lens on
the owl uh we meet Amelia Clark's
character Gaia and she uh welcomes a new
member to new skrillos uh scroll refugee
camp set up an abandoned nuclear plant
south of Moscow
um because
not American Moscow but if you're an
American against Russia you see it
however
hell yeah we're going to Moscow
um so they passed a mix of human and
squirrel faces Gaia explains that those
who sign up as Warriors have to stay in
their human form their shells so it's
harder for them to be identified by
humans and Scrolls and I'm sure the
makeup Department's like um I want a
joke you know kidding me they're like
budgets
can there be some actors that are humans
all the time yeah they're all practical
yeah yeah yeah and I think this is a
really interesting thing because in
Marvel Comics scrolls are the
shape-shifting aliens but for a long
time characters like Reed Richards of
the Fantastic Four or people like Tony
Stark or Bruce Banner they're smart
enough to know when a human is a scroll
so when they did the secret Invasion
comic book storyline one of the big
Revelations was not just Scrolls have
been infiltrating and taking over a
couple of different key characters but
it's also like oh we can no longer tell
our technology doesn't work on how to
determine who's a scroll that's being
disguised as a human anymore so I think
this is a way to sort of try to explain
okay if Scrolls have been on Earth since
1995 in the MCU if characters like Nick
Fury and other Top members of things
like Shield or the US government or
whatever are aware of them there's got
to be a technology way to figure you
know so so now she's saying if Scrolls
stay in their human form for longer
it makes it more difficult to be
identified I actually was like writing
down like how do we do that because
that's right that is like right I'm sure
it'll be interesting element I'm sure
it'll be answered yes
I don't know how to differentiate and
it's like the only real Tell-Tale sign
is strength yeah yes or are they out
themselves or careless in the comic
books it's about
um if a scroll if a character who you
think is a scroll gets killed and then
when they die if the body reverts to
scroll form that's really the only time
shoot first and ask questions later
basically it's very exactly
so yeah we learned that the the ones who
are not Warriors just have to stay at
home right uh and then Gaia leaves uh
Beto behind and she enters a room where
uh pagon pagon uh Graphics right-hand
man officiates the scroll officiates the
scroll taking an oath of loyalty to the
cause the room is lined with unconscious
humans attached to devices which we
later learn are called fracking pods I
love the name of this not to be confused
with Battlestar galactic Galactica with
fracking
or to be confused with the the process
of fracking yeah I think it means I
think it's both our influences there
um and you know at Battlestar Galactica
who's a Cylon the same kind of mystery
right like the whole time it's gonna be
a mystery political Intrigue laced
throughout absolutely yeah um so once
the scroll completes his oath the human
is brought in and it's like I like that
they have to look at them face to face
it's it's very unsettling
um and likely one who believes in the
AAR cause you know we don't need to feel
too bad about him but this girl takes
his physical identity uh the human is
thrown into the fracking device where
the scroll then quote takes his mind
takes his memories I I wouldn't mind now
that you've mentioned Galactica like I
was straight away thinking what are the
limitations and there's only like sort
of six or seven forms that they can take
uh like you know so when you see that
particular human you know it's a Cylon
what are some of the limitations here
because not only can they take form they
can take multiple different forms if
they've just seen them they can then
extract their memories
like what are these limitations that we
have because this is Feeling Again going
back to sort of the parallels we have in
in the universe in the earth like covert
was very similar you didn't know who had
it and it was like spread like wildfire
and it was hard to contain with a
million Scrolls now on the planet with
no limitations
I think there are one limitation is
their ideology their fact their
diasporatic status the fact that they're
uh they feel like strangers in a Strange
Land that and I think that makes them
it's not really vulnerability and in
some ways graphic is weaponizing it as a
strength that they can use to Rally to
this cause of uh kicking out the humans
or eradicating humans from the planet
but yeah I think they're they're rage
their anger uh the Loyalty The
unflinching loyalty that they have to
have to each other is like the one thing
that limits them the fact that they
can't they don't have the privilege of
just settling and assimilating I also
think that um
yeah yeah and we're so used to in sci-fi
stories like Battlestar Galactica or
there was a um the recent season of Star
Trek Picard the last season had like
um changelings was also like a whole
element in that storyline and even if a
scroll can take a human being's memories
does that also mean personality does
that also mean I don't think skulls were
born with an Australian accent so
they're picking that up from somebody
yeah who are they picking but but I'm
saying maybe there are limitations that
the show hasn't showed us yet where even
if a scroll takes a person's memory
could another person be able to identify
an imposter with like if they somehow
mess up if they like what does it mean
taking a person's memory like are they
completely covered in every single way
or they're going to be gaps in that
memory or that's what you're finally
conducive to the body that they're in
right it's like right right sense memory
right if you have like triggers like uh
physiological triggers to certain
scenarios a fight or flight instinct is
grounded in your memory I mean there's a
lot of like uh Neuroscience that goes
into what is a personality it's just
kind of like memory and you look at
people who have like Alzheimer's or
dementia and they kind of lend lose
their senses of self a little bit
because they don't have their memory to
inform their emotional reactions to
scenarios and even their physical
reactions and it also sounds like
they're saying stick to the one body in
mind and let that become your entire
identity shape-shifting a bunch of
different humans what a thing to ask a
scroll it almost feels like the
Americans you have to let go of your
previous identity The Americans FX to
show The Americans okay you have to let
go of your native identity yeah and
adopt this other identity that feels
foreign to you and that's what these
scroll Warriors have to do they have to
stay in human form and stay and you're
right exactly they have to stay in the
skin of the people they're trying to
conquer and that's got to do something
to them right like that's a limitation
you gotta you feel gross in the skin
that you're in well I think that's why
we're seeing more and more it's like
when they're able to sort of like
have time to themselves they do revert
to their original form they do revert to
their original language you know to kind
of keep them unified as a scroll right
yeah yeah let's move forward so later
Fury uh Hill and Taylor's identify a
group of squirrels who may build a bomb
thanks to Fury's camera at Sonia's and
they set off to meet him uh pagans and
skya to purchase the bomb she beats the
team there and she makes the purchase in
spotted by Hill leaves with a package
interrogation of the bomb maker goes
south reveals himself to be a scroll and
fury kills him uh much to Taylor's
disappointment and his sadness he
doesn't want to see squirrels die he's
still kind of an optimist
um I also think think you know hearing
from another scroll you know you're
betraying us I think yeah yeah and I
also thought there was a bit of a
middle-aged like a crisis moment here
where Fury was like I'll help you and
Taylor's is like I don't need help I'm
younger and more fit than you yeah I'm
not even 40. really yeah right so I feel
like oh maybe that was a little bit of a
Talos being mad that he kind of failed
being able to resolve that without
getting to help the intervention having
to kill the scroll certainly but it's
also like a failure on talos's physical
capabilities and like how he's able to
handle the situation yeah
um so he faces a second wave of
disappointment after joining Hill and
pursuit of Gaia attempting to reason
with her he informs her that her mother
passed away mother saw him it's an
important detail that Soren died we're
going to talk more about that later but
uh he pauses But ultimately or she
pauses But ultimately pushes him away
taking the bomb with her Fury and he'll
meet at an old bar and again he is told
that he's not ready for this fight this
is really getting pushed on us at this
point yeah like he's hearing it from
Taylor so he's hearing it from uh Sonia
he's hearing it from Maria time and time
again like he's hearing it from Roadie
he's just like that is the number one
message you ain't what you used to be my
man yeah yeah this is Very Old Man Logan
everything these days is Old Man Logan I
mean it's not fair that Samuel Jackson's
been old the entire time that's true
that's true that's true again what did
he get for his midlife crisis The
Avengers yeah
um so Hill's Comet seems to cut deep as
it triggers a flashback of when he was
blipped so after delivering the bomb
Gaia calls a secret meeting with Talos
to inform him of Graphics plan we think
she says there's gonna be three bombs
three couriers in a square for a
celebration of unity day and she tells
them each bag would be marked with
infrared spray the next day Talos Hill
and fury donating some infrared
detecting glasses go to the square in a
tense Chase we watch as the three split
up it's a shell game I love this kind of
scene who's got the bomb uh they try to
follow the Mark's bags and Chaos of the
celebration we land on Fury he sees an
individual who takes the forms of
peoples we have seen him encounter
throughout the episode the little girl
from the Men in Black come on child with
a weird little why does that girl
playing with the ball on the street
after Fury was just warned you can't uh
you're gonna at least stick out walking
around at night in Moscow um we see the
woman on a date we see a man from the
bar all these people it's kind of like
that moment at the end of Loki episode
two where like uh you know Sylvie
transforms into different forms uh where
it takes the the body of different forms
but this is a threat saying we're
following you right we've been yeah
we've just been toying with you this
whole episode what I love this moment
this girl this girl leads him closer and
closer to the center of the square as
taylorson Hill close in the figure
reveals themselves to be gravic and Hill
and Taylor's grab the bags they find out
that they're empty graphic hits the
button triggering three explosions a
square set of the Panic it's a gruesome
Massacre we have to imagine hundreds if
not a couple thousands that's huge I
mean Wars have been started over less
folks um our Trio try to reunite Hill
being called Over by Fury who shoots her
and the second Fury the real Fury runs
up as Hill's killer turns out to be
gravic and disguise Fury grabs Hill who
dies in his arms and Whispers it was you
and I liked the different takes that we
had on that was it it was you you shot
me and she doesn't ever know that it
wasn't him or is it the warning it was
you you've got to find someone because
they're using your face yeah it's it's
such a chilling final words right like
uh and and you know how Fury hears it he
doesn't hear as a warning he feels the
blood on his hands now for letting her
die and that's that's where we end
things like just panning up and up and
up and then because we knew that Soren
is dead there are no outs here Maria
Hill Kobe Smulders is gone yeah and I
think uh I love as well that we are
seeing this be very very contained and
because this is political this is
America versus Russia we are seeing this
as a classified Venture so it's like
it's only who needs to know Nick Fury
has been running this campaign for
decades so he's kind of like the one
calling the shots I think he's making
promises he actually can't keep agreed
and that's a really dangerous thing
because all this girls are doing is
holding him accountable funeral I
promise that he's made yeah so I kind of
like the fact that when you are picking
off these people who are in and can be
be the ones that help and when you have
like the team's getting smaller and
smaller chaos is going to erupt because
you know the solution's disappearing I
mean it's a perfect challenge for the
MCU version of Nick Fury yeah because
the one thing he's been able to do is
detect when people are bullshitting him
uh to be a step ahead multiple moves
ahead three steps ahead uh which aren't
that many steps Chess Masters can stay
like four steps ahead he gets taught a
lot of steps you would think that he
could see like a combination of chess
moves that would get to a Checkmate in
eight moves maybe but three's not that
many because you know if your three
moves behind you can see the three moves
ahead of you anyway I just thought like
more moves please
um but let's let's ask the question if
this first episode ends with the promise
of a major MCU character dying yeah I
feel like that sets up a promise that
other characters are gonna die we
already have the highest body count I
think of any single MCU title because
like we learned in the Civil War that
like the Battle of New York only it had
a pretty small death count I might be
wrong in the numbers here but in a
Disney plus title for sure sure so let's
go through some options of who do we
think we'll die and specifically in the
show what if entire realities were
wiping that's true that's Doctor Strange
yeah but they're they're animated
realities
but you're right you're right you're
right um so do we think this show is
going to end with Nick Fury dying okay
likely no yes only because Samuel L
Jackson love the paychecks yeah okay and
he's in the Marvels but we I feel like
the Marvel's is not going to be a show
that takes place before this show I
think it's going to be post okay and I
think at one point same Jackson says
something like the show secret invasion
is going to explain why Nick Fury is
where he is in the Marvels up on the
saber station or whatever like he said
something like secret Invasion has to
happen for before we get to the Marvel
like it's like it's like the one before
the other but it would be wild if they
killed off Nick Fury and then like a
scroll takes his place it's like Mendo
or something and then he's like well now
I'm just Nick it happens yeah exactly
exactly so I but I'm gonna say
likelihood of Nick Fury dying is going
to be like
five percent out of 100 like it's very
very I'll set it at 15 okay that
probably more fair for me and I'm only
saying 10 because Nick Fury has been the
connective tissue since day one yes he
was the original Iron Man in 2008 so
this is the guy that we call upon to
usher in the new people because we are
in Phase five isn't it we're phase five
this is Phase five yeah yeah so it's
like we are seeing the original Avengers
already sort of say goodbye so Nick is
dementor he use the Father Figure he's
the one that sort of like has to be
steps ahead but he's the one that has
all the information and I think that
he's such an important character he
doesn't need to be there all the time
yeah but I think that his presence is
necessary especially agreed yeah I
always go through with new characters
with younger characters yeah let's talk
about Taylor's okay I put Taylor's death
odds at 90 100.
hey what do you guys think so because I
think that someone has to die someone
bigger has to die at least to the stakes
of this show and uh oh I've got it so
what's
stopped halos
personating graphic you know if gravity
becomes more of a crucial role oh then
like Scrolls can like yeah it's like you
have to maintain the face and so what he
is if he is able to sort of infiltrate
and become gravity and then they think
that they're killing the enemy but
they're actually killing the outline
why not yeah they think they're killing
grab it grab it but they're actually
killing them now
oh wow what about if I think that that
uh talos's uh daughter in the show is a
very interesting character Gaia very
interesting I love Emilia Clark I'm so
happy that she's a a part of this show
as well talking about a stacked cast
She's a great actor I wonder if by the
end of this series Talos will die but
Gaia will switch alliances and this and
realize her mom and dad were right to
side with Nick Fury to be on the side of
these Good Guy characters and maybe she
will become almost like a new Talos and
become an ally to either Nick Fury going
forward or saber or more Avengers
characters or so on because I also have
to imagine you can't you're not Clark
and be like but you're only in this show
she's also would get like you could
right well if we're in the Spy Thriller
genre I think guy is going to be out
Alias Sydney Bristow
I think that you know
um we're going to learn more about sort
of where her allegiances lie and we're
going to think that she's going to be
working for graphic the entire time but
I think she's going to use that Intel to
stop him once you know when she was
first announced as being a part of the
cast my comic book Brain went oh I think
she's going to be playing Spider-Woman
who is a Marvel Comics character who's
the variety yes he's a very important
scroll slash not scroll character in the
Marvel Comics I know Spider-Woman is a
scroll sometimes and I thought ooh and
then Emilia Clarke could play The Scroll
version but then when the scroll version
gets killed she still stays on as
Spider-Woman like the real human version
of the character Jessica Drew not the
animated though right yeah but what's
very interesting about what you said mod
is that for me the Spider-Woman
character in Marvel Comics is a double
triple agent she's worked for Hydra
she's worked for shield she's worked so
so it's this great like a potential
character to be able to swap alliances
whenever the story needs it and I feel
like Amelia Clarke could do something
like that so you might be yeah I think
they're setting her up to play the
Abigail brand figure I think she might
be set up to take over saber and sword
like you gotta imagine that Amelia
Clarke signs on to it she's probably
going to be a Redemptive character she
starts in this place of betrayal to her
father I think by the end of these six
episodes she's going to come to the fold
and be able to broker a piece between
the Scrolls and humans this is such a
twisty tourney show that I thought that
when they introduced her and she was
with graphic I went and when we realized
that she was Taylor's daughter I thought
oh maybe she's just working with gravic
but she's actually secretly working for
a dad the whole time but then that scene
happened where the dad confronted her
and Taylor's had to tell her your mom
died and I'm like that scene was just
with those two characters she really did
not know she really has separated from
her dad and her mom and and like really
has her own but when you see how uh
she's left out of the big meetings she's
like you know she's not a part of sort
of what's going on uh and she integrates
new members as if she's like doing a
good service she's like she's like
welcome welcome yeah she believes in the
cars she believes in the cars so I think
that you know like so many great
complex antagonistic characters they may
have a cause you agree with but maybe
she'll realize hey these methods are too
much same sort of thing happened in the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier with the
with the Morgan fowl Carly Morgan fowl
characters black Smasher same sort of
thing happens with fans and killmonger
we all love Michael B Jordan's
killmonger even if we were like too far
you went too far but we agree with you
you got left out yeah yes so maybe a
Redemptive character it might be but if
guy is her scroll name yeah could she
then become could her human form be
Abigail that's what I like she could
take on the name okay
um or they could intro like because when
they announced uh Olivia Coleman I was
like oh Olivia Coleman could be the
Abigail brand of this world we don't or
they could just introduce another actor
to be Abigail brand I think the MCU
needs an Abigail brand uh I mean Nick
Fury seems to be playing that role in
the Marvels but I think it'd be a great
opportunity to introduce someone else to
take on that leadership one thing some
of us um off screen some of the
producers in us were talking yesterday
uh that it might be good to introduce
this scroll like these terroristic cells
uh country by country why not just
introduce the flag Smashers as one of
those like you could wreck livestock for
sure John was that you who I was talking
to might have been uh
smashes that don't understand the
concept of a flag smash I think all of
us are still unsure exactly what they
were trying to do but this was the group
in the back of the winter soldiers who
had the red handprint masks you can also
go back further and be like you know you
know uh uh in the 10 Rings what if
there's a few 10 Rings cells that are
also Scrolls you could do whatever you
you know you could say Hydra people were
Scrolls you could say like and it's
actually really
really like yeah an initial story story
and then they retell it by looking back
and go actually this is what really
happens baby retroactive continuity I'm
all about it getting back to the
question of who do we think will die I
think president Ritson is gonna go only
just because we've already announced
Harrison Ford is going to play the U.S
president oh yeah Captain America new
world we don't know where Harrison Ford
is in the MCU right now we have to
imagine he must be vice president or
somewhere in the order of succession
vice president depends how long uh Brave
New World takes place after secret
Invasion but it seems like by showing us
the White House correct me if I'm wrong
is this the first time we've been inside
the White House in the MCU I know Iron
Man 3. Robert Redford Robert Redford was
in like the state department and he
mentioned like I think knowing the
president or something right like right
yeah I don't know if he was in the white
house also I'm going back all the way to
2003 I'm like X2 X-Men United right
crawler was in the white house but
that's not the MCU that was Alan
cummings's Nightcrawler right president
Matthew Ellis and Iron Man 3 which is a
reference you know the Warren Ellis but
fun fact about Iron Man 3 that was
Wednesday Adams she was a little girl in
that movie
played the little girl who was in a
wheelchair in that film oh cool who was
she was a little kid yeah that was 2013.
we're old we're all of us are so old
yeah the uh I do think I loved the shot
of going up the stairs and you see past
US presidents but they stopped at Reagan
because at that point you start getting
into modern political history but also
and we need to have a different timeline
Nixon and then Reagan made me go like I
don't trust this President I don't know
what's happening here I don't like these
people like this guy is that since like
the 70s because we know the Scrolls even
though they didn't come onto the planet
Earth until 1995 those refugees were in
orbit since the late 80s because that's
when Annette bening's character became
acquainted with them so like at that
point any of those U.S presidents could
have been infiltrated like the fact that
we stopped on Reagan but this is
story in a way because
it's simple and yeah by going we could
have even been I don't know you know
what's funny when the secret Invasion
comic book was coming out they did a
bunch of like variant covers of like
different Marvel characters that we had
like the scroll chin to be like who do
you trust you know whatever and I think
they did a variant cover because it was
around 2008 where President Barack Obama
was a scroll like that's right Obama and
McCain I think it was during the
campaign
was actually a squirrel the whole time
yeah what if I am I'd still be your
friend are you a good scroller or a bad
scroll yeah do you like graphic or do
you like Talos I mean Mendo see you're
good you're a good scroll oh yeah
tell us not British thank God it's
Australian good yeah
but it turns you you brought some show
and tell that you wanted to recommend
anyone who likes secret Invasion really
quick uh segment here we're gonna call
It For the Love of Christ read a comic
book this is secret Invasion and the
first recommendation this week this is
the bigger picture I just want to say if
you have not read the original 2008
secret Invasion miniseries highly
recommend because it's very different
than the show but this storyline is sort
of like a big Blockbuster movie version
of this story it's almost like the end
game it's almost like what are Scrolls
in this for what are they trying to
accomplish and you read this and it's
the big bombastic every character is
involved but it's a very big public
version of this war and so many of the
other tie-ins for these comic books that
were happening in other comic book
series with other characters they're
more low-key they're more like showing
Nick Fury in that stealth mission mode
like realizing who's this girl who isn't
that sort of thing that I think is
closer and tone to the show but I want
to recommend this first for this first
week because it gives that great overall
bigger picture look and there's some
Great Moments including my absolute
favorite where Scrolls that are invading
Earth they're saying you know they have
a different motivation in the comic
books we know what the motivation is in
the MCU is that scrollos is not their
home world I guess and they've been
refugees and the comic books their
motivation is there is a fringe
religious extremist group of Scrolls who
according to their religious texts are
prophesized to inherit the earth it's
always going to be theirs according to
their religion there's some new home
that was in their prophecy and they
believe it's Earth they're taking on
stairs but in the name of their God and
at one point a scroll character says to
Nick Fury in this like our God loves you
our God loves you and Nick Fury replies
with yeah well my God has a hammer and
then Thor arrives and it's awesome and
that's a great line I have to say I I
would love if this if the show at least
references their religion because I that
is like my favorite thing about this
it's very interesting is that they have
this uh religious ideology because now
nothing nothing is more of a motivator
to go to war and to go on a crusade in
an invasive force in religion and if
they don't have their religion in the
show I'm gonna be a little bummed and
actually the fact that they have
building this community and like you
know we're seeing that there's
disruption within this community but I
really like that idea where it's like no
we're bonded together because it's
bigger than us right yeah it's for our
kids absolutely so check out the secret
Invasion and I think each week that we
talk about shows I'm going to try to do
like a different comic book
recommendation based on what we maybe
learned from the show or whatever so
check this out if you haven't read it
pretty good how publicous girls in that
is it a human level knowledge or is it
still classified it is um that's a great
question I think that in the Marvel
Comics Universe it's
human level knowledge because characters
like the Fantastic Four publicly dealt
with the Scrolls almost in the very
beginning of the sort of Marvel
Superhero stories but
this is the storyline where they become
the most most public everything kind of
up to this point you could read Marvel
Comics and go do the people on Earth are
they aware of all the that's going
on and usually no you
'll ever chalk things up to like it's
a theory or it was a weird uh electrical
storm that was happening like they don't
know things that are Galactus or that
are you know whatever but this storyline
they're very public in fact Scrolls take
the shape of celebrities
to get on TV characters even like
celebrities like Stephen Colbert who
makes a cameo and he's just like we love
you like as a scroll they're like we
love you you can trust us God loves you
let us know I'm wearing someone else's
body right Oprah Winfrey Stephen Colbert
they all make uh Cameo appearances in
this so very very public I won't be sure
to read this it's like it's required
viewing reading and viewing um just
stare at it okay next question we want
to ask coming out of this episode how
did Sauron die right the hands of the
enemy it's possible because the last
time we saw Soren this is also important
to know was when her and her husband
were in the car and they were
impersonating Nick Fury and Murray Hill
at the end of Spider-Man far from home
now in the MCU Avengers end game happens
in October or fall of 2023. it's
actually the year that they everybody
comes back which is kind of weird right
it feels very weird to the global
pandemic but it's weird so then
um then following year into and by the
end of Peter Parker's school year which
I think like June of the next year 2024
that's when Spider-Man far from home
takes place with Mysterio you know they
go to London and then at the end of that
we learn oh that wasn't Nick Fury at all
he's been off world since at least
Avengers end game because he comes back
and we saw at the end of Tony Stark's
funeral Nick Fury was standing there I
believe that was the Nick Fury not
Taylor right it's like that's probably
Fury who's there in person with
everybody else who wouldn't send a
stand-in exactly so maybe even from that
moment Fury peaced out but Soren was
alive at least until the following year
2024 and then from there to now which I
think we might be into it said current
Day present day 2024 2026 sorry 2025
maybe 2026. I think yeah they always
stay like three years ahead yeah at
least in Facebook so we're we're two or
three years post the Mysterio event
how did Soren die we don't know yet
according to this first episode we have
no idea so yeah but I think there's
there's been some conflict if it were if
it if Taylor's could prove that it was
someone part of gravig's group I think
he'd be more bitter and vengeful toward
Graphics group I think she passed away
he's kind of afraid of the pauses or
something I think there was some kind of
yeah I think there was but I don't think
it was like in Cold Blood I think she
might have been infering to try to get
her daughter back from The Fringe uh and
I think maybe Gaia didn't know that this
was happening and then one sworn got too
close they said okay we warned you and
she's gone now I think do you think
we'll see the deaths you think we'll
learn or it will just be an offspring
mention I I said full I feel yeah it's
always the Disney plus episode where we
learned some flashback to stuff okay
Everett Ross you're just a scroll now
was it just this particular Everett Ross
or has Everett Ross Been a scroll for a
long time and is the real Everett Ross
still out there somewhere so this is the
thing about having Scrolls now we can
question absolutely every story
everything Canon is now fluid you know
like it's been fluent just like gender
just like
gender's a construct I you know again
last time we saw Everett K Ross Black
Panther wakanda forever where he was
dealing with his ex-wife Val who by the
way I think she's a scroll that's what I
think I think they're both girls well
this is the thing you have to look at
the Timeline right that's what I'm
trying to do so black panther wakanda
forever was I also think the year
2025 I want to say in the fall of 2025.
um so and at the end of that film
because he was a fugitive from the law
Okoye rescued him from being taken
somewhere did she take him back to
wakanda did he live there did he did she
just free him and now he's like Off the
Grid and then if so did he get replaced
as a scroll from that point to now or
was he a scroll during that movie and
earlier
I think he I think something else more
recent happened because the rules of
this world established that when they
assume someone's identity they they put
them into in this cracking pod yeah so
that's my worry is it somewhere Martin
Freeman is in a fracking pod in this
comatose state because that's the only
way they can guarantee that the there
won't be two Everett Ross is running
around right correct so I think some and
the comic books had an excuse for
keeping characters alive
Excuse me while a scroll was
impersonating them like they had some
like oh we need them because we need to
be able to go to their DNA or whatever
like they had like an actual reason for
it I wonder if the show's gonna do it
and here's the other thing I think is
going to happen by the end of this one
season
I think that we're going to get the real
Everett Ross maybe we'll be like freed
from a pod they're gonna pan over and
you know who's gonna be in another pod
Val so that the audience knows oh she's
been a scroll like sort of a Val active
right now she's a scroll so either the
valve that we know is going to be in the
Thunderbolts movie is gonna be a scroll
or that will be the real vow at that
point the Contessa Valentina de Fontaine
but she'll have to take back her
identity from this point to that point
My Hope Is that they're both scrolls and
they don't know that the other is a
scroll and that's why they've had
Miracle issues no they're on the same
side they're just like you know there's
like a Millions potentially Scrolls that
are just walking around on Earth right
now do they all is there a way that a
scroll can detect another scroll no
they're perfectly matching DNA so I
think they're both scrolls and they just
didn't know it's like the the Rupert
Holmes song they were pina coladas
getting caught in the rain and then they
found their way back to each other but
they didn't realize that they're both
scrolls and then but they just sense
that there's some kind of Deceit going
on and that's why their marriage fell
apart so hold on that's my head Cannon
and it's fluid and Mr and Mrs Smith they
don't know that there's buys that's
right
now now we're really kind of looking at
everyone's being monitored yeah scrolls
are overtaking people in key positions
yes so that they can manipulate chains
of events so anyone who's in a position
of power is likely a target for a scroll
and now this is also going to be an
overarching theme Here anyone who is a
scroll again like whose body has been
taken against their will to a scroll can
I uh consume their identity is holding
somewhere yes likely in this refugee
camp yes there is just pods and pods and
PODS of people to be rested which is
scary because these are radioactive
sites that still happening and you're
bringing in human bodies that are not
resistant to radiation yeah maybe
they'll Shield them knowing we need to
keep our little cargo pressure the
fracking pods are lined with like lead
and with concrete yeah those are
dangerous sites to for humans to just be
in for months and months and months
um but I do like the detail that like
Scrolls can resist it because their
their molecules are constantly shifting
they can just naturally adapt yeah
that's right to the Earth's soil what do
we think Nick Fury is doing on Sabers
right now great question I think it's
interesting that he left after Tony
Stark's funeral because that traumatized
him so much he's like I can't be on
earth right now he feels like he let
Tony Stark down he's like I recruited
this guy into the Avengers now he's dead
I need to just get off this planet I I
mean I think that there's maybe more to
that that he was just using that whole
thing as an excuse listen the dude got
dusted and he was barely able to send
off a beeper page to Carol Danvers after
30 years and she showed up from 1995
finally back to Earth but like what is
he doing on saber I think he might be
doing what Tony Stark tried to do in
Avengers Age of Ultron which has put a
shield around the earth a suit of iron a
suit of arms because Iron Man was so
traumatized by The Avengers movie
dealing with the chatari invading and
seeing that portal and you know and and
freaking out and he had that
post-traumatic stress that we saw in
Iron Man 3. so I think that his
motivations in Avengers Age of Ultron
made sense but then like he and Bruce
Banner did it the wrong way and they
created Ultron James Spader bad I think
Fury is going to try to do that same
thing but like in a better way it has to
be crucial because he's such an
important key figure so for him to be
gone for so long yeah it needs to be
something bigger than yes or like to
protect the entire entity of Earth but I
think at the moment it's been used as
this sort of like ostracized punishment
or like where he's like in his Batcave
dwelling or whatever it is so like
they're not going to unveil the
importance of it I think it's being
downplayed a lot where it's like wow
you've just changed a lot and you're a
bit of a Sookie lower right but we don't
know what he was actually doing like I
think that it is something incredibly
crucial and that would be an info drop
later and it might come it might yeah it
might come into play in the Marvels
because it looks like that movie is not
just dealing with Kamala Khan Monica
Rambo Carol Danvers but like other Cree
like a bunch of other space stuff and
you know we're going above Earth again
we're going above Earth again and in
Marvel Comics the cree scroll war is
such a huge pivotal thing for so many
characters and it's so important to so
many characters that the MCU really
hasn't full on gone into that they might
do their version of the cree scroll war
or us finally kind of seeing because
again the first Captain Marvel movie was
mostly just set on Earth it was about
Carol kind of remembering who she was
and dealing with Jude Law and a little
bit of this a little bit of that a
little bit of Cree but at the end of the
day they clearly like five strong that's
it it was it was Lee Pace just being
like I'll come back later like we saw
him in Guardians and that's it you know
but I think I think I'm glad he brought
up the crease scroll War I think that's
why Fury built the saber space station
and he's on it I think he's fighting
that shadow war and Spider-Man far from
home there was that line with him and
Maria Hills tales and Soren talking
about Cree sleeper cells there has been
a shadow War happening right now Furious
fighting decree and that is a battle
station I think the reason why he has
not found a new home for the scroll is
because he knows that the next time this
girl tried to find a new home planet the
cree are going to Massacre them so he
has to deal with the imperialist threat
of the cree right now and he's building
uh Battle Stations lightsaber and it's
called saber right it's not called
Shield it's an aggressive front and so I
think there are other space stations
he's trying to build around the Galaxy
to combat the threat of the Creed so
this is actually so much more than a
promise he can't keep right I think he's
trying to fulfill his promise as best he
can but it's about
yeah again in the comic books the cree
and the Scrolls have been fighting since
like the dawn of time like it's it's
gonna take more than like some
diplomacies a human guy being like Oh
wait let's meet at the table and let's
get one dude right the Korean the scroll
hate each other and it's a thousands of
years old conflict how is this going to
be observed resolved how is it going to
play into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you know it might be a great way to
introduce a character that is a young
Avenger who we haven't met yet Teddy
Altman AKA hulkling that's right half
crawl half screen you see it's a very
Romeo and Juliet story uh wait scroll
has scroll have created what did I say
crawl screen that's what I meant I mean
it's Romeo and Juliet it was like it was
like a scroll uh uh uh princess I think
in a Cree Warrior like fell in love even
though they were fated to hate each
other and then they made this child who
they knew would almost be the uniter and
then they hit they hid Teddy away on
Earth so maybe Secret Invasion if this
show doesn't introduce that character
and he eventually becomes a young
Avenger and he becomes friends with all
the other young Avenger characters like
Kate Bishop Hawkeye and Cassie Lang you
know so forth one territory then it is
that's right but but but I think we may
we might meet that character in the
Marvels yeah we might you know I don't
know it's it's it's really really
interesting to see what the MCU is going
to do with that whole thing but that's
what I think I think you guys are right
about this that's what saber has been
for and we're going to learn more about
what Fury has actually been doing yeah
it's kind of like when the United States
uh and the U.N decided to create or
recreate the nation of uh Israel oh God
what am I doing
um you need to be an aggressive
imperialist uh presence around the earth
to be able to defend and properly
fortify that country from all the people
who are trying to destroy it and I think
you can't just say hey this girl hears
your new home World fine you're on your
own now you have to carry a big stick
and be the policeman of the Galaxy at
that point you have to be the new Nova
Corps I think that's what Fury is trying
to do I haven't seen that in a minute
either they were devastated by Ronan the
Accuser in 2014 according to the Galaxy
all right we're gonna leave it there for
this episode of inside Marvel we have
six episodes this season we're so
excited to talk about and uh next week
we're gonna be talking about episode two
we're very very excited for that
reminded to subscribe to the Deep dive
Channel subscribe here to the break room
subscribe to the new Rockstar's main
Channel that's where the Easter egg
breakdown is coming out uh you can
follow me at ya boss follow mod at mod
Garrett hello Ed Hector is funny uh
subscribe to inside Marvel wherever you
get your podcast be sure to support us
by grabbing some merch at nerdright.shop
and we'll see you next week bye
everybody
foreign
[Music]